[Musik]
herzlich willkommen so zdf heute live
hier geht es heute um harten tobak denn
wir stellen die frage ob der staat in
der korona krise versagt das zumindest
sagt der kolumnist und autor sascha lobo
und damit hat er offenbar einen nerv
getroffen oder zumindest eine debatte
angestoßen die wir heute aufgreifen
wollen wo genau läuft es nicht rund ist
das wirklich staatsversagen ist es
überhaupt versagen oder täuscht der
eindruck und in wirklichkeit läuft es
eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht diese
und mehr fragen wollen wir stellen in
der nächsten halben stunde einmal an
sascha lobo persönlich der es uns aus
berlin zugeschaltet und dann wollen wir
danach auch mit berlins regierendem
bürgermeister michael müller sprechen
und beiden könnt ihr kennt das eure
fragen stellen
unter diese e mail adresse hier und da
freuen wir uns auch wie üblich auf und
über eure kommentare
wo glaubt ihr zum beispiel liegen die
größten probleme und welche noten würdet
ihr den politischen entscheidungsträgern
geben nur ein paar vorschläge für das
was sie ihr gerne uns hier schreiben
könnte jetzt aber erstmal guten namen
nach berlin
sascha lobo kopenhagen hatte schon vor
der letzten ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
bevor diese neuen kohler beschlüsse
gestern getroffen wurden vorgestern
abend was geschrieben von flip sätzen
setzten die dich ausflippen lassen sind
seitdem das geschrieben als neue flip
setzte dazu gekommen
ehrlich gesagt konnte ich das in der
tiefe gar nicht verfolgen weil so ein
flip satz ja noch wahnsinnig belastet
als ich gelesen habe dass angela merkel
in der unionsfraktion tatsächlich gesagt
hat wir brauchen sicherlich den monat
märz für eine test strategie in
deutschland da bin ich halt so
ausgeflippt habe ich gemerkt das kann
ich nicht mehr seitdem versuche ich auch
so ein bisschen einfach diese ganz
krassen setzte die für mich ausweis
eines staatlichen eines staatsversagen
sind so etwas zu umschiffen ich halte
einen solchen satz nur einmal die woche
aus wenn überhaupt weil sie wirklich
eine zumutung
dass man eine test strategie im märz
wohlgemerkt 2021 ankündigt und nicht im
märz 2020 der sprichst du die
schleppende geschwindigkeit an die sich
ja nicht nur beim testen zeigt wir
werden gleich darüber noch etwas genauer
sprechen
kurze frage noch zu den aktuellen
beschlüssen was war denn inhaltlich
deine erste reaktion als du die neuen
corona beschlüsse gehört hast das würde
ich am liebsten auf einer metaebene
kommentieren denn nach einem jahr
pandemie glaube ich ist die allererste
pflicht des staates klar und simpel zu
kommunizieren damit man versteht worum
es geht es hat ja nicht jeder die zeit
sich einfach ganztags mit diesen
maßnahmen auseinanderzusetzen
und wenn dann ein eng bedruckte sin elf
punkte papier mit 17 verschiedenen
farben in die kamera gehalten wird was
so unglaublich mit sieben verschiedenen
schritten komplex ist und dann zwischen
35 und 150 und immer hin und her dann
glaube ich als incidents wert dann
glaube ich ist das so komplexen so
kompliziert dass die leute sagen hey was
soll das ich weiß überhaupt nicht mehr
was wo wie gemeint ist es ist völlig
über kompliziert wie wo was man da tun
soll und es ist aus meiner sicht auch
nicht sauber argumentiert und das würde
ich sagen die beschlüsse die wir jetzt
sehen sind zur teilweise eine ergänzung
eine erweiterung eine aufweichung eine
verschärfung ist es alles andere als
wirklich klar was man wo wie wann darf
und das halte ich für fatal
das hat ja auch viel mit kommunikation
zu tun auch ein großer kritikpunkt nicht
nur von dir und deine kritik du sagst
dass du beantwortet auf der metaebene
weil die doch durchaus tief greifender
ist es ist ja jetzt nicht an einzelnen
beschlüssen fest gemacht sein ärger
viele dieser gründe dafür liegen ja
schon jahre zurück die folgen haben sich
während der ganzen pandemie gezeigt wir
haben mal zusammengefasst wo man
defizite schwierigkeiten und probleme
erlebt hat in den vergangenen zwölf
monaten sommer 2020 zehntausende
reiserückkehrer die an bayerischen
autobahnen auf corona getestet wurden
bekommen tage lang ihre testergebnisse
nicht auch rund 1000 positive proben
sich nicht zuordnen der grund weil keine
technik zur verfügung stand wurden
papierformulare benutzt die teils
unleserlich ausgefüllt wurden nächste
baustelle impfstoff bestellungen die
eu-kommission zögert zunächst die
neuartigen und teureren m rna impfstoffe
von beyond advisor und moderner zu
bestellen weil viele mitgliedstaaten auf
konventionellere impfstoffe setzen
wollen
auch bei den schulen gibt es probleme
als im letzten herbst die zweite welle
losrollt wird den schulen empfohlen
einfach regelmäßig zu lüften
der vorsitzende des deutschen
lehrerverbands fand das als strategie
erbärmlich als es dann wieder einen
distanz unterricht zurückgeht bereichen
in mehreren bundesländern die
lernplattformen zusammen nicht besser
läuft es bei den corona tests eine
nationale test strategie soll erst bis
anfang april stehen die komme zu spät
und sei zu unkonkret sagen kritiker
schon im letzten jahr hatten experten
eine strategie gefordert wenn die
schnelltests dann kommen wird man sie
auf jeden fall nicht in die korona waren
app eintragen können
auch sonst hat die app in die einst
große hoffnungen gesteckt wurden nur
bescheidene erfolge vorzuweisen
eine zusammenschau das sagen wir mal
kollektiven kopf schüttelt könnte man es
nennen
sascha lobo spricht sogar von
staatsversagen und dafür gibt es viele
gründe die du nennst lass uns das doch
mal nach und nach durchgehend ein hast
du eben schon indirekt angesprochen
dein flip satz war angela merkels satz
dass es jetzt im märz eine strategie
geben soll bzw erarbeitet werden soll
das hat die auf die palme gebracht weil
es für etwas anderes steht die die
langsamkeit mit der viele sachen
angegangen werden wie erklärst du dir
das denn
ich erkläre mir das aus einer vielzahl
von gründen das ist also nicht
monokausal was da passiert aber ich
glaube diese gründe sind nach 16 jahren
angela merkel
fast alle direkt verbunden mit angela
merkels mit der kanzlerinnen art zu
regieren
und da glaube ich ist so viel schief
gelaufen im vergangenen jahr das man
durchaus von staatsversagen sprechen
kann erst recht weil eine dimension ja
immerhin ist das durch die extrem
langsame impfstrategie die deutschland
macht das ist noch nicht mal ein viertel
von dem was zum beispiel großbritannien
pro kopf schafft was schon dadurch
menschen sterben nachgewiesenermaßen
sterben menschen wenn man langsamer
impft und in dem moment wo der staat
falsche schlecht oder langsam handelt
und es sterben deshalb menschen finde
ich ist das begriff staatsversagen
durchaus gerechtfertigt im grunde ich
würde etwas mal mit fehlenden wumms in
diese kerbe haut auch andrea braun über
facebook sie sagt nein der staat versagt
sich das virus ist der feind und wir
sind leider zu lasch und zu große jammer
köpfe um das konsequent zu bekämpfen ist
das dann tatsächlich der staat oder
liegt das da nicht an den personen ist
es nicht eher ein politiker versagen
dann also ich finde ab einem bestimmten
punkt muss man gar nicht mehr auf krampf
trennen zwischen staatlichen strukturen
die tatsächlich faktisch versagen und
den handelnden personen die als
exekutivorgane wie die bundesregierung
ja immerhin den staat linken und den
staat zu verwalten haben wenn das in die
verwaltung reingeht ich denke schon dass
wir es hier zu tun haben mit einem so
tief greifenden auch strukturelle
versagen dass ich den begriff für
gerechtfertigt halte ich bin auch
nicht bereit zu diskutieren man muss
sich einfach mal 20 minuten anschauen
was irgendwie die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz für unfug
schon verzapft hat und das glauben nicht
nur ich sondern das glauben inzwischen
sogar ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten selbst die sich dazu
äußern und sagen oh gott wir haben
fehler gemacht oder wenn man sich
anguckt was manuela schwesig sagte was
da alles schief gelaufen ist und wenn
man sich anschaut was die
kultusministerkonferenz alles so von
sich gibt die nach einem jahr pandemie
ernsthaft empfiehlt immer noch zu lüften
statt einfach in jedem verdammten
klassenraum in der bundesrepublik
einfach ein luftaustausch oder viren
filter eingebaut zu haben und das sind
mechanismen die hängen sehr eng an
staatlichen strukturen am föderalen
system an fehlenden zuständigkeiten an
der langsamkeit an der fähre
digitalisierung und so weiter und so
fort das alles sind aufgaben die der
staat hätte schon vor jahren wenn nicht
jahrzehnten hinkriegen müssen und zwar
müssen und nicht können und das finde
ich diesen begriff sehr gerechtfertigt
nun sind natürlich auch föderale
strukturen zu was da und wir haben ja
auch die positiven seiten davon schon
gesehen dass man etwas gezielter und in
den verschiedenen bundesländern dann
auch unterschiedlich auf die dortige
panini situation reagieren kann zum
beispiel auch bürokratische strukturen
sind ja auch für andere sachen gut sag
ich mal sie schützen uns vor willkür zum
beispiel ist das wirklich alles so
falsch sascha oder wird nur das falsche
draus gemacht
ich möchte erst gar nicht auf krampf die
das föderale system in der
bundesrepublik gleich im klosett
runterspülen das ist nicht so natürlich
hat vor der realität ab föderalismus
auch vorteile
aber immer dann wenn in notsituationen
die handlungsfähigkeit so massiv
beeinträchtigt ist muss man sich fragen
ob das richtig umgesetzt wird und da
würde ich mich gar nicht darauf
einlassen ob das jetzt im prinzip gut
ist aber hier faktisch schlecht wir
haben einen föderalismus und zwar den
real existierenden föderalismus und wenn
der in einer notsituation wo es um leben
und tod geht im weg steht dann muss er
tiefgreifend reformiert werden und das
ist für mich so eindeutig dass ich
glaube wir müssen hier post pandemisch
unbedingt massen nach steuern sowie die
bundesrepublik moment von regierung und
verwaltung aufgestellt ist gerade was
auch die große koalition an
glaube ich wird sehr klar und sehr
eindeutig wie viel versäumt worden ist
und wieviel nicht gemacht worden ist
obwohl es hätte gemacht werden müssen
eine zentrale kritikpunkt bei ihr ist
die wie du sie nennst die sparwut in
deutschland dabei haut ja die
bundesregierung moment milliarden aus
land wirtschaftshilfen aber auch
natürlich direkt für die pandemie
bekämpfung die neuverschuldung wird im
kommenden jahr man weiß es noch nicht
genau wo sie liegen wird aber geschätzt
wird sie bei mindestens 230 milliarden
euro in diesem jahr
warum spricht trotzdem von der sparwut
oder dem deutschen geiz also zum einen
dass die neuverschuldung für 2020 viel
viel geringer ausgefallen weil man dann
eben doch nicht so viel geld ausgegeben
hat zum zweiten ist die sparwut ja etwas
was in den vergangenen 20 jahren mit
dieser bekannten schwarzen null zu einem
substanzverlust geführt hat wir gehören
in deutschland zu den schlechtesten
ländern in europa was die digitale
infrastruktur angeht und das merkt man
in der pandemie jeden tag zwischen den
schulen und den vielen menschen die im
home-office noch nicht mal eine
vernünftige videokonferenzen bekommen da
ist viel kaputt gespart worden und dann
sehen wir wie bis heute gesundheitsämter
quer durch die bundesrepublik noch vor
digital arbeiten und irgendwelche daten
hin und her faxen und natürlich ist dass
sie direkte folge davon dass man 20
jahre gespart hat ich möchte mir erst
mal erklären lassen warum die
bundesrepublik maßgeblich und
federführend dazu beigetragen hat dass
die eu ernsthaft beim impfstoff einkauf
versucht hatten besonders guten preis
herauszuschlagen stadt zu merken war so
ein lock down ist so teuer da ist völlig
egal wie viel der impfstoff kostet das
wird immer billiger sein als vier fünf
sechs monate lockdown die jetzt
eventuell drohen fünf oder vier oder
fünf haben wir schon hinter uns
ich glaube also die deutsche
bundesrepublik die deutsche
bundesregierung verzeihung die hat zum
falsches möglichen zeitpunkt gespart und
das liegt an dieser ekligen sparwut die
sowohl cdu als auch spd vor sich hin
getragen haben
ich glaube die gehört als allererstes
abgeschafft und da wirklich mit der
bazooka geschossen und nicht nur mit der
olaf scholz
wenn ich mir anschaue wie heute
selbstständige solo selbstständige
behandelt werden denn ist das unter
aller sau die unter kleine unternehmen
gerade behandelt werden dann ist das was
die wirtschaftshilfen angeht unter aller
sau wirklich monatelange verzögerungen
und ich finde das katastrophal
ich glaube jemand hat sogar ausgerechnet
dass ich einen preis von 1500 euro pro
dosis noch gerechnet hätte wenn man den
lockdown dagegen rechnet nun gibt es ja
diese vorwürfe lange und politiker
hatten auch schon die gelegenheit darauf
zu antworten und da hören wir vor allem
von finanzminister scholz ja nur durch
die schwarze null der vergangenen jahre
schaffen wir jetzt überhaupt die
besucher heraus zu holen und so viel
geld auszugeben und argument nummer zwei
ist natürlich generationengerechtigkeit
das was wir jetzt an schulden aufbauen
das müssen die nächsten generationen
abtragen was antwortest du darauf darauf
antworte ich sehr hart weil das quatsch
argumente sind dass zum einen die
verschuldung von deutschland wenn die
irgendwo zwischen 60 und 70 prozent
liegt und man sagt wir müssen trotzdem
immer noch sparen weil da war sie
nämlich vor der pandemie und die usa mit
über 100 prozent und japan sogar mit
über 200 prozent
von r schuldenquoten ganz gut zurecht
kommen dann halte ich das für quatsch
dass man unbedingt immer noch weiter
sparen muss das ist der erste punkt der
zweite punkt ist
generationengerechtigkeit dann würde ich
gerne die generation selber noch mal
fragen und nicht olaf scholz
denn diese generation sagt naja moment
eine sache sind irgendwelche schulden
die wir vielleicht irgendwann mal
irgendwer nach vorn abbezahlen muss aber
das andere ist dass wir in deutschland
eine katastrophale digitale
infrastruktur haben die man eigentlich
als investition hätte betrachten können
oder sogar müssen und da es
generationengerechtigkeit für mich viel
eher ein funktionierendes lang zu
hinterlassen als irgendwelche schulden
in höhe von 60 70 oder 80 prozent
wir reden hier ja von einem sehr reichen
sehr wohlhabenden land was über
jahrzehnte auf substanz gelebt hat und
deswegen ganz viele sachen nicht
funktionieren und irgendwie von
generationengerechtigkeit zu sprechen
wenn in berlin
irgendwelche schulen keine
funktionierenden klos haben das halte
ich wirklich für eine unverschämtheit
mein eindruck ist dass viele deinen
eindruck teilen vielleicht nicht
unbedingt staatsversagen aber zumindest
das sehr viel schief läuft und
das macht ja was mit den menschen also
vertrauen kann gehen dadurch
politikverdrossenheit kann entstehen
welche folgen befürchtet du durch ja
dieses scheitern will ich jetzt nicht
nennen aber zumindest die die großen
defizite die hier sich bei werden in
vielen dingen ja ich finde ich finde
scheitern auch zu positiv dass danke
dass du das noch mal erwähnt ich glaube
ich glaube dass ein groll entstanden wie
ist in den menschen eine form von
schweren davut die haben einfach keinen
bock mehr sich das bieten zu lassen die
haben einfach keinen bock mehr dass
deutschland nur ein viertel so schnell
impft wie zum beispiel großbritannien
oder das ist in den vereinigten staaten
inzwischen dass fast 70 millionen
menschen games sind und in deutschland
krebsen wer eben noch mit irgendwelchen
quoten im einstelligen prozentbereich
ich glaube dass langfristig das
vertrauen in die institutionen die zu
einer demokratie gehören massiv
beschädigt worden ist nach einem jahr
pandemie wenn man dann immer noch merkt
man hat sich nicht richtig vorbereitet
man hat nicht rechtzeitig mit gedacht
man hat nicht rechtzeitig investiert man
ist immer noch geizig gewesen da
irgendwelche sachen wann immer noch zu
teuer
dass da die menschen eine wut und einen
groll entwickeln der die demokratie
tatsächlich beschädigen kann weil er zum
beispiel das vertrauen in parteien
massiv infrage gestellt hat sascha lobo
herzlichen dank für das gespräch wo
viele denkanstöße dabei waren und viele
werden wir damit jetzt aufgreifen mit
unserem nächsten gespräch da wollen wir
mit michael müller dem regierenden
bürgermeister in berlin sprechen für
dich erstmal danke schön nach berlin und
den abend ja ein paar heftige vorwürfe
waren dabei und wir wollen natürlich
auch den angesprochenen regierenden
entscheidungsträgern gelegenheit geben
darauf zu antworten alle können wir
natürlich nicht ihren studio holen
deswegen stellvertretend heute abend bei
uns berlins regierender bürgermeister
michael müller auch in seiner funktion
als vorsitzender der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz guten abend
nach billigen
guten abend hallo
ein scheitern des staates staatsversagen
sagte sascha lobo das kommt ja einer
glatten 6 gleich wenn man mal ehrlich
ist welche note würden sie sich geben
sich und den anderen
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten und der kanzlerin
ja auf jeden fall eine deutlich bessere
weil ich glaube dass man nicht nur einen
ausschnitt betrachten darf das nicht
alles perfekt gelaufen ist das sagen wir
auch alle das wissen wir auch alle aber
im nachhinein ist man natürlich immer
schlauer
nur es gibt eben auch viele positive
dinge die man sehen muss wie wir in der
medizin in der gesundheitsversorgung
helfen konnten menschen aus anderen
ländern haben wir aufgenommen die tests
und die impfstoffe wurden in deutschland
entwickelt wir haben in berlin innerhalb
von 48 stunden mehrere hundert millionen
ausgezahlt an kleinst selbstständige das
gehört dann zur betrachtung alles mit
dazu also unterm strich es stimmt es ist
nicht alles perfekt gelaufen aber weit
entfernt von einem staatsversagen
sie sagen im nachhinein ist man immer
schlauer das ist sicherlich so man hat
immer gut reden wenn man wenn man weiß
wie es gelaufen ist und hätte besser
laufen können
allerdings muss man auch sagen man hat
auch viele warnungen und
expertenmeinungen in den wind geschlagen
das war schon lange vor der pandemie als
man nicht auf die szenarien die es gab
geschaut hat die im grunde genauso ein
pandemie verlauf schon vorgezeichnet
haben
man hat nicht auf die unkenrufe gehört
dass eine zweite welle im raum stand das
war ja schon im april mai juni im
frühsommer vielen experten klar
man man hat andere sachen nicht
angepackt wie wie erklären sie uns das
warum hat man da auch das was man im
vorhinein vorfeld hätte wissen können
nicht angegangen ist
wenn sie sagen man hat meinungen in den
wind geschlagen dann suggeriert das ja
dass es eben nur die einer meinung gibt
und nur den einen aspekt in der
betrachtung der situation und wenn es
und das ist dann nimmt auch nur eine
entscheidungsgrundlage gibt die man
nicht berücksichtigt hat aber das ist
nicht der fall
es gab und gibt bis heute auch in der
wissenschaft unterschiedliche positionen
wie man gut
auf diese ganze situation reagiert es
stimmt es gab von anfang an auch viele
ernstzunehmende warnung deswegen hat es
ja sofort auch ein hartes eingreifen im
märz und april gegeben aber es gab dann
auch stimmen aus der wissenschaft die
unsicher waren wie wird zum beispiel
sich das infektionsgeschehen an der
schule entwickeln
wie wirken impfstoffe in den
unterschiedlichsten bevölkerungsgruppen
auch all das war beratung der
wissenschaft für die politik
und es kommen auch andere aspekte
jenseits der gesundheitsfragen natürlich
mit hinzu sozialpolitische
gesellschaftspolitische
wirtschaftspolitische und auch da gab es
viele meinungen die wir haben einfließen
lassen es ist immer eine gratwanderung
wie schützt man bestmöglich leben und
gesundheit das ist ganz klar das
wichtigste für uns alle
aber wie gehen wir auch mit den
sozialpolitischen folgen um wenn man an
kinder und jugendliche denkt die nicht
in die schule gehen können wenn man an
das familienleben denkt ganz unabhängig
noch mal von der wirtschaft die
natürlich auch große probleme hat und
insofern gibt es nicht die eine einfache
antwort und es gibt auch kein anderes
land das die eine einfache antwort und
den königsweg gefunden hat es gibt aber
andere länder die in verschiedenen
fragen einen deutlich besseren weg
gefunden haben als wir in deutschland
bei mir hinten beim impfen zum beispiel
also wir alle wissen wie weit vorne
israel ist auch die usa haben uns da
überholt sogar viele überhaupt das am
dritten februar angefangen haben zu
impfen
auch in europa und wir teilen die in
europa die in der eu die gleichen
probleme dass wir zu wenig impfstoff
haben und trotzdem ist deutschland nur
im unteren mittelfeld
wenn sie sagen andere länder sind da
besser gefahren dann und usa impft mehr
stimmt aber wir können auch gerne
vergleichen wie die infektionszahlen und
die todesraten in den usa sind und wie
viele opfer das gefordert hat bis sie
angefangen haben zu impfen
und wir müssen betrachten ob die usa
auch wirklich bereit es sich mit anderen
abzustimmen oder ausschließlich die
eigene produktion für sich selbst
verwendet
alles das sind dinge die man mit
berücksichtigen muss und wir sind
einmal ein land mitten in europa und uns
ist dieses gemeinsame vorgehen in europa
wichtig wo sich nicht der schnellste
oder stärkste alleine durchsetzt und die
anderen gucken in die röhre
und ich habe verständnis für die kritik
und kritisiere selbst dass die
entscheidungsprozesse in der eu zu lange
gedauert haben das hätte anders laufen
müssen das ist so ein punkt wo man sagt
es ist nicht gut gelaufen so etwas hätte
nicht passieren dürfen dass aber der
ansatz richtig ist dass wir anders als
die usa uns mit anderen ländern
abstimmen und gemeinsam vorgehen wollen
das wiederum finde ich richtig
also man kann sich nicht die das
sahnehäubchen raussuchen von den jeweils
anderen und sagen guck mal die machen es
doch besser ohne dann auch andere
aspekte mit zu betrachten die mitunter
eben dann auch schwieriger
rahmenbedingungen deutlich machen wobei
sich das ja nicht ausschließt man kann
ja trotzdem gemeinsam entscheiden und
vorgehen eine linie finden und trotzdem
schnell sein
das sage ich ja gerade ich sag ja hab
denken ja gerade gesagt dass ich auch
finde dass das so ein punkt ist den man
auch wirklich sehr kritisch sehen muss
und so etwas darf nicht wieder passieren
entscheidungswege müssen deutlich
schneller funktionieren auch wenn man
sich so viele staaten miteinander
abstimmen müssen das ist mit sicherheit
nicht gut gelaufen der ansatz war
richtig die umsetzung war schlecht nun
hat man aber den eindruck das ist wieder
so passiert wenn wir nämlich die test
strategie sehen wir sehen jetzt dass wir
erst eine taskforce bekommen die im märz
erarbeiten soll wie die schnelltests
laufen sollen und vielleicht wissen sie
es nicht aber unsere user können uns
kommentare und fragen schicken und da
möchte ich gerne von enigma aufgreifen
über youtube wieso hat man das mit den
corona test so versäumt andere länder
machen es vor beispiel österreich die
frage leite ich gerne an sie direkt
weiterhelfen aber noch einmal österreich
als positives beispiel zu nennen
finde ich schwierig um es mal ganz
vorsichtig zu sagen es ist ein aufzug
auf zu auf zu in österreich man kann mal
zwei drei wochen einkaufen gehen und
sich ins café setzen und dann ist aber
auch wieder zu für alle
die urlaubsgebiete werden aufgemacht
aber nur zeitweise oder nur regional und
dann wieder zugemacht es wird getestet
auf teufel komm raus sehr gut am
trotzdem hat man eine 200er incidents
sehen sie das ist der punkt den man eben
auch mit berücksichtigen muss was will
man erreichen mit einer test strategien
wir haben eine test strategie auch ich
sagte das für mein bundesland für meine
stadt ja seit tagen seit wochen haben
wir das angeboten und sind in der
umsetzung für die lehrerinnen und lehrer
zum beispiel wir haben tests angeboten
in testzentren und es wird leider sage
ich gar nicht so groß abgefragt wie wir
es uns wünschen würden
und wir werden jetzt demnächst wenn die
selbst test zur verfügung stehen bisher
sind sie ja noch gar nicht in dem maße
da aber wenn sie jetzt zur verfügung
stehen die die auch anwenderfreundlicher
sind werden wir sie anbieten für die
kinder und jugendlichen in den schulen
das muss man eben auch mit
berücksichtigen dass wir ein angebot
machen können dass uns auch zur
verfügung steht im entsprechenden umfang
und auch in der entsprechenden anwendung
dann auch wirklich umsetzbar ist und in
dem moment wird ist auch gemacht hier
muss man ganz klar sagen bei den tests
bei den schnell und selbsttests ja wir
brauchen auch da noch zusätzliche noch
mehr kapazitäten völlig richtig wir
müssen mit testen und impfen unsere
lockerungsschritte absichern
die kritik ist berechtigt das muss jetzt
auch laufen aber es ist nicht so dass
wir bei null anfangen wenn sie sagen sie
haben gute angebote aber sie werden
nicht in dem maße abgerufen wie es
verfügbar wäre also das trifft ja nicht
nur die test das trifft ja auch die die
impf angebote für mit astrazeneca im
stoff wenn ich richtig informiert bin
ist zb bei ihnen in berlin-tegel dass
das impfzentrum das den astra zenica
impfstoff verabreicht ja steht fast leer
das sind tausende impftermine offen das
hat ja auch mit kommunikation zu tun
also das teilen sicherlich diese beiden
bereiche hat man da was versäumt die
bevölkerung mitzunehmen
ja dass wir wir kommunizieren über ich
habe es auch gestern und vorgestern
wieder gemacht bei allen
pressekonferenzen und habe alle dringend
gebeten auch ihre möglichkeiten zu
nutzen die es gibt diesen astra weniger
impfstoff auch in anspruch zu nehmen und
die termine auch wirklich wahrzunehmen
denn da wird uns ja jetzt auch von der
wissenschaft attestiert dass er sehr
wohl hilft vielleicht sogar besser auch
noch als andere impfstoffe und auch ab
der ersten impfung schon hilft und
insofern werbe ich überall dafür dass
auch in anspruch zu nehmen
aber natürlich es ist für die politik
dann auch schwer
auch äußerungen die er wiedergekommen
sind auch aus der wissenschaft und
vorbehalte man weiß nicht so richtig für
wen ist gut wirkt ob für die älteren
genauso wie für die jüngeren und ob
schon ab der ersten impfung oder erst ab
der 2
das alles dann auch wieder zu
korrigieren ist sehr schwer aber auch da
muss ich sagen wir haben jetzt sie haben
tegel eben angesprochen schon deutlich
mehr nachfrage
das hat sich also auch durch mediale
unterstützung muss ich sagen fernsehen
zeitungen haben sehr viel
aufklärungsarbeit geleistet in den
letzten tagen da hat sich auch die
haltung schon wieder verändert und wir
haben jetzt deutlich mehr gebuchte
termine als in den letzten tagen und
können damit eben ja auch deutlich mehr
menschen sofort helfen und das ist gut
das ist gut dass wir diesen impfstoff
auch zur verfügung haben und ihm nun
auch entsprechend einsetzen können wird
kurz noch bei der kommunikation bleiben
wollen denn viele user fragen deuten
darauf hin dass ihr offenbar noch nicht
genügend erklärt wurde zum beispiel
schon galler 79 schreibt uns auf
facebook
wieso wird geöffnet wo die mit mutante b
11 7 das ist die britische krone warnte
variante exponentiell wächst und jede
zweite woche die fallzahlen sich damit
verdoppeln da wurde offenbar das nicht
richtig transportiert warum sie jetzt
doch diesen lockerungs plan in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz beschlossen
haben
das spiel mehrere dinge eine rolle
natürlich sehen wir das mit sorge was da
jetzt angesprochen wird dass die
infektionszahlen nun seit mehreren tagen
bundesweit stagnieren und dass diese
mutante uns nach wie vor beschäftigt
oder uns noch mehr beschäftigen wird
aber wir sehen eben auch auf der anderen
seite nun schon im verfolge dadurch dass
die älteren durchgeimpft sind die
pflegeheime durchgeimpft sind sehen wir
dass die todeszahlen nach unten gehen
und die belastung in der intensivmedizin
auch abnimmt wir es haben eben gerade
darüber gesprochen das testen und impfen
ja parallel läuft ja auch mit dem ganzen
öffnungs strategien und immer mehr tests
angeboten werden für immer mehr
bevölkerungsgruppen genauso wie immer
mehr impfstoffe zur verfügung stehen
und deswegen sehen wir auch gerade da
wieder in der abwägung zwischen
gesundheitsschutz und auch anderen
interessen die mit zu berücksichtigen
sind soziale wirtschaftliche und dieser
abwägung sehen wir jetzt eine
möglichkeit vorsichtig ganz vorsichtig
und nur stufenweise mit öffnung zu
beginn weil wir jetzt eben diese
instrumente zur verfügung haben und ich
bitte auch daran darum sich daran zu
erinnern dass wir im letzten frühjahr
gesagt haben die harten maßnahmen
ausgangs beschränkungen demonstrations-
einschränkungen und und und die sind so
lange nötig und wichtig solange wir
keine anderen instrumente haben und nun
haben wir seit dezember ende dezember
letzten jahres haben wir einen impfstoff
zuerst zu wenig jetzt wird es immer mehr
wir haben jetzt neue testmöglichkeiten
mit diesen selbsttests die problemlos
und anwenderfreundlich umzusetzen sind
und in diesem moment wo wir diese
möglichkeiten haben können wir uns
andere dinge zu trauen
das ist also etwas sagt was seit dem
letzten jahr kommuniziert wird wann kann
was passieren und genau jetzt sind wir
in dieser phase wo man sich das ein oder
andere vorsichtig zutrauen kann
wobei man natürlich auch sehr genau da
jetzt auf die reihenfolge schauen muss
die ersten geschäfte dürfen jetzt öffnen
die friseure haben schon wir reden jetzt
zb über baumärkte mit mit mit
gartencenter
die sogenannten körpernahen
dienstleistungen
aber wir haben im moment die strategie
noch nicht es gibt die tests aber wir
testen noch nicht es gibt die impfungen
aber flächendeckend sind sie einfach
noch nicht möglich jetzt gerade riskiert
man nicht dass man jetzt wieder ein hin
und her bekommt dass die vielleicht
wieder schließen müssen weil die zahlen
steigen bevor man mit den waffen die wir
haben zu schlagen kann
bin mir nicht sicher also einerseits
natürlich haben sie recht es muss noch
mehr werden ja das sage ich auch und das
muss jetzt auch schnell vorangehen dass
wir die tests alle ausgeliefert bekommen
die wir brauchen aber wir können auch da
schon wieder sehen was hier alles
passiert wir haben jetzt über die
discounter in diesen tagen die ersten
angebote für diese selbsttests ich habe
gerade aus berlin berichtet wir bieten
zwei mal die woche für die lehrerinnen
und lehrer kostenlose tests an
wir haben jetzt angeboten auch als
arbeitgeber für menschen in der
verwaltung tests testmöglichkeiten und
viele andere private arbeitgeber machen
das inzwischen ja auch und wenn sie und
wir haben im parallel dazu immer mehr
geimpfte und wenn sie das nebeneinander
legen dann ist das doch schon eine
ordentlich große gruppe von menschen die
praktisch ständig überprüft wird in der
frage liegt eine infektion vor oder
nicht oder sogar schon einen impfschutz
haben auch jüngere bekommen hierzu nimmt
den impfschutz in berlin haben wir die
berliner polizei jetzt reingenommen in
das impfen die lehrerinnen und lehrer
sind als nächstes dran genauso wie die
erzieher
also sie sehen dass das parallel
laufende systeme sind und ich betone es
hier zum wiederholten mal nicht perfekt
und nicht alles ist sofort da so wie man
es sich wünscht
aber es ist auch keinesfalls so dass da
nichts passiert und dass wir blauäugig
in eine öffnung reihen laufen ohne dass
das begleitende maßnahmen gibt herr
müller wir haben auch noch experten
gefragt verschiedene wo deren meinung
nach die größten defizite im
krisenmanagement
liegen unter anderem haben wir den
verwaltungswissenschaftler professor
wolfgang seibel von der universität
konstanz gefragt er sieht einen
wichtigen grund in der schleppenden
digitalisierung und wir sagen ihnen wenn
man kurz in wort und bild was er genau
gesagt hat ich denke andere länder
kostet er jung ist darauf an welches
wort mal meint haben zwei vorteile die
wir in deutschland nicht haben ein land
wie dänemark etwa ein relativ kleines
land mit einem einheitlichen
verwaltungssystem kennt zum beispiel
keinen föderalismus es gilt in ähnlicher
weise für die kleineren baltischen
staaten aber wir haben eben außer dem
föderalismus mann der damit verbundenen
starken dezentralisierung gut fragt mit
ehrung die wir geschafft haben mit der
wir eigentlich ansonsten sehr gut
bereich kommen das problem dass wir eine
latente reserve gegenüber der durch
technologisierung der verwaltung haben
die sehr viel zu tun hat mit dem etwas
sonderlichen deutschen verständnis von
datenschutz voll datenschutz für sich
genommen ist ja schon etwas merkwürdig
begriff denn eigentlich geht es ja um
den schutz unserer privatsphäre aber in
dem moment wo es um daten geht sollten
ja es auch der schutz von daten nicht
wichtiger werden etwa als der schutz von
leben und gesundheit von menschen und
das ist natürlich eines der zentralen
probleme mit dem wir es hier zu tun
haben ob der schleppende verlauf der
digitalisierung der verwaltung der
schadet uns ja in dieser pandemie krise
praktisch auf allen ebenen das betrifft
insbesondere die gesundheitsämter aber
es betrifft auch besonders starken maße
die schulen der jetzt viel drin männer
greifen wir mal ein punkt raus weil mit
blick auf der uhr sie müssen gleich los
wir nicht mehr so viel zeit haben die
schleppende digitalisierung die hat sich
ja jetzt nicht erst in der korona
pandemie aufgebaut sondern über jahre
warum hängen hinken wir in deutschland
da anderen vergleichbaren staaten so
hinterher was ist wann von wem konkret
verpasst worden
da muss man erst mal eindeutig sagen da
hat der professor recht mit seinem
statement und ich sehe das genauso da
hinken wir wirklich hinterher und das
ist tatsächlich auch ein ergebnis von zu
wenig oder falschen investitionen
digitalisierung treiben sie nun mal auch
natürliches muss auch eine entsprechend
positive haltung dazu geben man muss es
wollen
aber sie treiben ist eben auch ganz
konkret über investitionen voran man
muss dinge erneuern und modernisieren
und das ist über jahre nicht passiert in
der verwaltung das muss man ganz
kritisch selbstkritisch sagen wir haben
andere schwerpunkte gesetzt und das holt
uns jetzt ein und da gibt es bundesweit
auch bei uns in berlin gibt es einen
dringenden nachholbedarf es gibt nur
wenn ich das noch hinzufügen darf
trotzdem bewegungsspielraum das thema
europäischen datenschutzrecht das kann
ich nicht von heute auf morgen auflösen
auch da gibt es wieder verständigung mit
denen man arbeiten muss die man nur
schrittweise vielleicht wieder in eine
andere richtung korrigieren kann aber
wir hätten zum beispiel auch ein
handlungsspielraum gehabt für diese
berühmt berüchtigte low carb die ja nun
wohl doch viel unterstützen kann an
möglichkeiten gerade im zusammenhang mit
der öffnung strategie ein problemloser
datenaustausch es damit möglich ich
hätte das gerne in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz entschieden
dass wir sie jetzt als grundlage nehmen
und sie mit einbauen in unserer öffnungs
strategie und da gab es vorbehalte
so etwas ist bedauerlich nicht jetzt das
große rad drehen wollen von heute auf
morgen und sagen europäischer
datenschützer keine rolle mehr spielen
dafür heben wir uns aber unsere
möglichkeiten stärker nutzen das wäre
schon der erste wichtige schritt gewesen
und wie gesagt das bedauerlich auch dass
diese chance nicht ergriffen wurde
ich hoffe dass wir dazu noch in der
nächsten woche kommen und dass das dann
nachgeholt wird und wie diesen beschluss
auch wirklich fassen können da sind wir
schon mal ein blick in die zukunft
letzte frage reicht brinkhaus der
unionsfraktionsvorsitzende hat gefordert
nach der pandemie eine art kassensturz
zu machen und ganz klar zu bilanzieren
wo es was wie schief gelaufen wo gab es
defizite können sie uns versprechen dass
das passiert ja das muss passieren
es findet auch jetzt ja schon statt es
finden ja auch jetzt schon ständige
korrekturen stadt und die parlamente
hinterfragen regierungshandeln völlig
richtig und das wird immer wieder in die
eine oder andere richtung justiert und
wir müssen diesen kassensturz machen und
zwar nicht nur in bezug auf finanzen
sondern insgesamt auf zum thema pandemie
bekämpfung um zu lernen aus dieser zeit
aus negativen wie positiven dingen zu
lernen denn mir sagt die wissenschaft
dass wir uns damit auseinandersetzen
müssen dass solche dinge auch in dichter
folge passieren können dass wir uns mit
viren mit pandemien mit
naturkatastrophen mit solchen dingen
zunehmend in einem internationalen
netzwerk auseinandersetzen müssen und
dann muss man aus den gemachten
schritten lernen und ich finde es falsch
pauschal zu sagen alles ist gut gelaufen
dass es genauso falsch wie zu sagen
alles schlecht gelaufen sondern wir
müssen aus positiven wie negativen
erfahrungen lernen für die zukunft und
wir hoffen dass der live stream heute
dazu beigetragen hat michael müller
herzlichen dank dass sie uns rede und
antwort gestanden haben einen schönen
abend nach berlin und an alle unsere
user ebenfalls herzlichen dank fürs
zuschauen fürs beteiligen ich hoffe wir
haben eine spannende debatte geliefert
mit zwei spannenden gästen
wir wünschen noch einen schönen abend